it's really scary to even think about it
when i'm gonna tell jenny
that
i'm not ready for the marriage right now
submit
lesson learned okay be careful what you
ask for because you might get it when a
soldier came to my house he told my
parents to allow us to get married after
fighting for nine years to marry ginny
the opportunity is here and cement is
freaking out and i mean really freaking
out i'm feeling like from top to bottom
it's everything shaking this man's
anxiety got so bad that he ended up
doing something ridiculous behind
jenny's back
no he don't know about it
you just being a jerk we're gonna talk
about it plus did you cheat oneri ari's
mom janice asked binyum what we all want
to know and of course he gave the answer
we already knew he would give
no
but did she believe him there's a lot of
visual cues to someone's answer let's
get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
i know the number of you who have said
submit does not want to marry jenny
are saying i told you so right now after
all his hard work it's evening chicken
he is shaking in his boots oh look at me
i'm shaking my little space boots good
to see you at the top of the episode
they want to be astrologer to see what
would be the best time for them to get
married now that submits parents agreed
to not stop them as per the styles you
can get married after nine days from now
and you may get married after a month
two months that doesn't make difference
but auspicious time starts after nine to
submit surprise the astrologer said
[Music]
jenny was clearly happy and cement tried
to act as if he was
now before they left the astrologer
mentioned that they have to get married
in the court and not a temple because if
they get married in a temple the
relationship won't last whatever you do
it is to be done in the court the
problem with getting married in the
court is that it's a longer process than
getting married at the temple and
understandably jenny wants to get
married asap because she doesn't want to
worry about her visa anymore which means
that she is ready to start filling out
that paperwork now god willing
everything will go good
okay
oh my god it's very quickly it's
happening very quickly
i thought i'm gonna take up at time
but you know that like now
it's here as you can get married now
the nerve was staying like wolfie is
starting i wonder if the stars told the
astrologer what submit was about to do
he's obviously fallen in love with the
idea of marrying jenny and not the
reality i don't know if it's part of our
human nature or what but we tend to be
attracted to things that are hard to get
and then once they become accessible the
allure
goes away but scratch that cement's been
through hell and back for this cause
family division and everything
we will talk illegally
he needs to get it together
[Music]
i'm not pressuring you right i mean you
want this also like i do say i said like
i love you i know you love me i did
respect the fact that cement went on to
be honest with jenny about the way he
was feeling he says all this fear and
hesitation is coming from the trauma he
experienced in his first marriage he is
afraid that jenny will change after they
get married and he doesn't want to get
another divorce right now i'm talking to
you and i'm feeling like from top to
bottom
it's favoring shaking i mean i watched
you go through hell and that was that
broke my heart for all of my lovey-dovey
people out there who aren't totally over
submits behavior just yet his
vulnerability led to this moment where
we really got to see the special
connection he and jenny share and how
much jenny loves him
so right now
what happened baby
okay
what happened baby what's happening
that's okay talk about it you need to
submit express how he doesn't want to
lose ginny because she's basically his
everything
it happened again it's gonna be very bad
it's not gonna happen again baby you
know how much i love you
i'm not going anywhere you can't get rid
of me if you try
but her words didn't take away what he
feels and if you've ever dealt with
anxiety before
which i'm sure many of you have you know
that even when you realize that there is
nothing to fear
that doesn't stop the thoughts from
coming and side note hopefully he's not
using his past relationship as an excuse
i'm giving him the benefit of the doubt
here we'll make an application
you have to provide certain documents
fast forward to the day where they go to
the lawyer to figure out what they need
to do to get married in the court jenny
assuming that submit felt better told
the lawyer that she's ready to start the
paperwork now because it's going to take
around 30 days to get it approved if you
want to file it today we can file you
today the application form smith said
uh-uh look at him shaking his head
and i'm getting married nervous
hey no nervous he said that he was
surprised that they were filing today he
thought they were just there to get
information process has commenced yay
considering how submit's feeling i'm
panicking too
that gay
yay
sounds a bit creepy yay
it's about time
i'm excited and happy right now this is
the first step to starting our marriage
process once they got in the car submit
was overtaken by fear i feel like then
i'm on a speeding train then i cannot
jump out of it yeah
a train that you were the conductor on
submit
thankfully a day or so afterwards submit
called his friend who was also cool with
jenny and he gave him some sound advice
now i'm i'm i'm a bit scared of madison
scared of what
i love these 90 day friends there is
always a sensible one that comes through
at the right time bro you know that
you've been fighting for the same thing
for a long time
and you have gone through a whole lot of
worst scenarios only one person who has
gone towards his journey because she had
left everything
she left her family behind everything in
the u.s just because of youth i
understand you've been married and it
found worse for you
but first thing it was an arranged
marriage right you didn't know the girl
so why the hell are you comparing jenny
with your class
jenny is a totally different person
facts narage you go on the wall of the
real 90 day mvps the voices of reason
who are needed in this 90-day world
niraj also tells them that he needs to
talk to somebody which i agree
to be honest but here is the moment that
shook the table
okay
submits friend could sense that he was
holding back something is there anything
you know telling me
that's when submit revealed after he and
jenny finish meeting with the lawyer
that night he called the lawyer and told
him to put the marriage paperwork they
just filed and jenny was so happy about
yay
on hold i asked him to hold
like in don't file uh for the marriage
uh
no he don't know about it
now you again you know
doing something wrong because that will
break her first
maybe just being a jerk
it's really scary to even think about it
when i'm gonna tell jenny that
i'm not ready for the marriage right now
this could spoil our future this could
call our relationship it could be the
end of the relationship
and i don't want that to be helped we'll
unfortunately submit the government does
not care about your indecision she needs
those papers it's not about you only
it's about you and jenny snap snap
all right let's briefly talk about
binium revealing to ariela's mom if he
cheated on her or not during last week's
episode we saw ari confront binium about
his behavior while she was in america
and he was in ethiopia what have you
done to disrespect your family i i don't
want
i don't want to fight
the day following that back and forth
janice took benny to lunch let's be real
okay let's talk about reality and cut
straight to the chase by the way make
sure you look at bingham's body language
when he answers her question when ari
was going
did you cheat on harry
[Music]
no
who said i don't believe him
it was a sit back and smile for me what
was that about but surprisingly mrs
janice took benyam at his word
i just had to ask
he knows that's what is she thinking but
no it does not like to absolutely it's
not like that's so there's not another
girl in your life if i have another girl
why i'm coming here like yeah
that's the question
i believe he's telling me the truth that
he did not cheat on harry
there's a lot of visual cues to
someone's answer so i feel relieved that
he said no and that his eyes said no
also yeah
i think we saw two different visual cues
but she was with him in person so
hopefully she read them right
no i don't see why he would treat ari
the way he did for two months she cried
so much if he wasn't getting attention
from somewhere else
hopefully he didn't cheat i don't want
him to cheat on ari but i wouldn't be
surprised if he crossed some boundaries
that's all i'm saying we talked about
the last couple months what's been going
on
once they got back to the house janice
told aria about her conversation with
binium i actually asked him was there
somebody else was there another
relationship that he was interested i
mean i you know me i
didn't
spare any words right i asked you
everything yes
i guess that's my question again are you
satisfied with it with every answer that
you've got today do you feel that his
answers gave you hope that things can be
fixed
yes binham is like yay yay got through
that one it looks like ari's gonna give
that relationship another chance or at
least she's open to it there's a lot of
work that needs to be done to rebuild
the trust
but it's really up to him to show me
that he values the relationship enough
not to make the same mistakes
time is the ultimate truth teller
well next week submit tells jenny the
truth about how he blocked their
marriage paperwork we're going to be
able to marry in about 30 days
after filing that marriage application
i put it on a hole
this is stupid i'm not doing this
anymore don't let him use you the day
you leave he will make a decision
if i want submit to know how serious i
am then probably i should go
just walk away
oh if only it was that easy to just walk
away
what is it ever that easy there are some
rumors that jenny and cement did end up
getting married though but we'll just
have to wait and see
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
you